on a snow-bound road west of Kiev where
months earlier Russian tanks had rolled
war crimes investigators from Ukraine's
Center for civil liberties are following
in their tracks in an old Honda Jazz
they've come to the Village of makariv
to record the testimony of a woman who
says her husband was killed by the
Russians
and here is where Alexi died from what I
know he was struck with something sharp
like the handle of a knife or a rifle
stock behind his left ear then they
brought him here and killed him five
stab wounds to the chest her mobile
phone contains a wealth of evidence her
descriptions are Stark and matter of
fact
here is where his best friend Andre was
shot in the head this is what was left
after his body was retrieved I have many
photos
and Alexi's body was here to be honest I
have no idea who put his body in the
boot of the car here you can see the
spot we are standing where the car was
parked
it's a painstaking business collecting
evidence of alleged war crimes like this
a process repeated already thousands of
times and there may well be thousands
more and they don't even know for sure
whether these crimes will ever be
prosecuted there is no International
tribunal yet at which to try them our
website is a Tribunal for Putin and it's
our database of war crimes so you can
see the number of
incident Moro 25
000.
certainly this is a process that will
take time however we must collect this
information so nothing gets lost are you
confident that these crimes will be
brought to Justice
yes I'm confident Justice will happen
Justice may be slow but the certainty is
reassuring for this Widow of the war and
many like her Jonah Al Jazeera makariv
Ukraine